I remember you speaking about the harmonics on it, that's not the until you're on them,
but cannot find your teaching explanation of what that is and what it means.
Remember, you are looking for something you can look on our website and search the word
harmonics.
I don't know if I had a blog post on that, but certainly on our video page, if you searched
harmonics or harmonics, but sometimes take the plural, you'll find a couple videos that
I did on harmonics on our video site.
But in general, harmonics is actually a musical term when they're talking about frequencies,
but it is a term when you talk about physics of a harmonic of a frequency.
So a harmonic is a multiple of a frequency, so let's say you're ready to frequency of three
hertz.
The first harmonic would be six hertz, the second harmonic would be nine hertz, third harmonic
would be 12 hertz, the 11th harmonic would be 36 hertz, because it's 11 times that number
33 hertz.
So that's what a harmonic.
So when we're running, when we're ready 11th harmonic, why are we already the 11th harmonic?
What's the significance?
It was just found in some testing that running the 11th harmonic of a frequency that is
known to kill, let's say a pathogen or known to kill a cancer cell, and you run the 11th
harmonic of that frequency at the same time that the kill rate is so much higher and I
do share, there's a video of a data practitioner, but a physicist, I think he's out of Georgia,
sharing it on a 10-ton.
There's a video on our website about that.
He was killing all the perubesium or something, but a frequency and then when he added the
11th harmonic of that frequency, completely destroyed, blew up the perubesium, or it was
a bacteria.
I can't remember the video.
I've watched it for a long time.
So that's what the benefit of harmonics is, and that's why I like that, until you're
around, because you can run a harmonic at the same time.
So there are different programs that I've written that have the harmonics written in them.
Certainly all the pathogen programs, anything that you're trying to kill, a little bit of
organism, anytime you try to kill, cancer, you're using the 11th harmonic frequency.